[Musik]
>> ELA: Herzlich willkommen zu Elas und Samiras
und Sallys Welt!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Genau in der Reihenfolge, nicht?
Elas, Samiras, Sallys Welt.
Gehört dir der Kanal?
>> ELA: Nein, dir.
>> SALLY: Echt?
Cool!
Ich dachte schon, sie hätte alles übernommen.
Du?
>> SAMIRA: Ich auch.
>> SALLY: Also herzlich willkommen zu unserer Welt!
Heute backen wir einen richtig leckeren
und vor allem sehr einfachen Kuchen
mit Joghurt, Erdbeeren und Rhabarber.
Mögt ihr Kuchen, ihr zwei?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Sehr gut.
Also starten wir direkt.
Ich zeige euch mal die Zutaten.
Wir verwenden dafür
100 Gramm Erdbeeren,
300 Gramm geschälten Rhabarber,
10 Gramm Zucker,
30 Gramm Stärke und etwas Vanilleextrakt,
drei Eier, die zimmerwarm sind,
175 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Zitronenabrieb,
jeweils 150 Gramm Naturjoghurt und Sonnenblumenöl,
275 Gramm Mehl
und eineinhalb Teelöffel Backpulver.
Ja. Die Erdbeeren, die habe ich bereits gewaschen
und geviertelt.
Samira, du kannst ja den Rhabarber schneiden.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Den haben wir auch schon geschält.
Und zwar, guck mal,
in solche Stücke.
Also so ungefähr einen Zentimeter dicke Scheiben. Okay?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann einfach hier rein.
>> SAMIRA: Ich mache hier den Krallengriff.
Das macht man dann einfach so.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Damit man sich nicht
>> SAMIRA: Schneidet.
>> SALLY: in die Fingerkuppen schneidet, nicht?
Genau.
Und immer nicht drücken, sondern schön schneiden.
>> SAMIRA: Ich mache das dann immer so.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Dass die Fingerspitzen innen liegen.
Perfekt!
Dann scheide du mal weiter.
Und, Ela, du darfst
die Eier in die Rührschüssel geben.
>> ELA: Erst mal eins.
Dann zwei.
>> SALLY: Ui!
Ah, da ist noch Eiweiß drin!
>> ELA: Und jetzt Salz.
>> SALLY: Ja, Salz rein.
Gut.
>> ELA: Der Rest noch.
>> SALLY: Oh, da ist noch drin.
Ja.
Und?
>> ELA: Salz und Zucker rein.
Mama hat ein bisschen zu viel Zucker rein.
>> SALLY: Nö, das passt schon so.
>> ELA: Aber ein bisschen zu süß!
>> SALLY: Das wird nicht zu süß.
Jetzt...
Am besten tauschen wir gleich ein bisschen die Plätze.
Jetzt darfst du nicht reinfassen, okay?
In die Maschine.
>> SAMIRA: Da nicht reinfassen in die Maschine.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und nicht so reingucken.
Da dürfen auch keine Haare drüber.
Okay?
Sonst verfängt sich dein Haar darin.
Also nicht reinfassen!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Ela, komm mal du weiter rüber.
Ich nehme dich mal.
>> ELA: Warum hat er sie nachgemacht?
>> SALLY: So.
>> SALLY: Da müsst ihr echt immer gut aufpassen!
>> SAMIRA: Ela, machst du das in die Schüssel rein?
>> SALLY: Jetzt schön verrühren.
Genau.
Du kannst die Erdbeeren auch dazu machen.
>> ELA: Ja!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Guck mal. Ich gebe euch mal eine größere Schale.
Ela, du darfst das mal hier rein machen.
Okay.
>> ELA: Nicht!
>> SALLY: Da ist noch einer.
Und hier, Samira, Vanille.
Oder soll Ela wieder Vanille?
>> ELA: Vanille ich!
>> SAMIRA: Ela, aber mach nur ein bisschen rein!
>> SALLY: Ich habe ein Déjà-vu.
>> SAMIRA: Mach ein bisschen
Vanilleextrakt rein, aber nur ein bisschen.
[Trommelwirbel]
Einen Tropfen!
Guck, Ela.
So.
>> ELA: Wow!
>> ELA: So.
Einen Tropfen.
>> SALLY: Okay. Wir machen einen Teelöffel rein, ja?
Komm, Samira, mach mal einen Teelöffel.
Ja.
Perfekt!
>> ELA: Warum muss da Vanilleextrakt rein?
>> SALLY: Weil es perfekt zu den Erdbeeren passt,
Vanilleextrakt.
Jetzt noch die Stärke.
Oi!
Und jetzt dürft ihr hier verrühren.
>> ELA: Ich darf aber!
>> SAMIRA: Du darfst dann auch gleich, okay?
>> SALLY: Darf ich den Deckel haben?
>> SAMIRA: Warum machen wir da eigentlich Stärke rein?
>> SALLY: Damit die Stärke
die Feuchtigkeit bindet
von den Erdbeeren und vom Rhabarber.
>> SAMIRA: Wir rühren zusammen.
>> SALLY: Und ich kann schon mal
den Backring einschlagen.
Ich habe den schon eingestellt auf 26 cm.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Samiras Backformtrick!
>> SALLY: Ist das Samiras Trick?
Okay.
>> SALLY: Samiras Backformtrick.
>> ELA: Und mein Trick!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Ich habe das von euch gelernt.
Was brauchen wir noch?
Eine Reibe.
Warte. Die hole ich hier kurz, Mäuschen.
>> SALLY: Vorsicht!
>> SAMIRA: Schmeckt nach Ei.
>> SALLY: Ja, das schmeckt nach Ei.
>> SAMIRA: Nach Ei und Zucker.
Noch nicht so lecker.
>> ELA: Ich möchte auch mal probieren.
>> SAMIRA: Nein, nein! Nein. Nein. Nein.
Oh!
Ich habe mir nur so einen kleinen Tropfen genommen.
>> SALLY: So.
Kommt. Den Rest machen wir jetzt so weiter,
damit ihr mithelfen könnt.
Warte mal, Ela. Du musst es nicht mehr rühren.
Das reicht schon.
>> SAMIRA: Das hier ist wie so eine...
>> SALLY: Also das Obst kurz zur Seite.
Ich gebe jetzt ein bisschen Zitronenabrieb dazu.
>> SAMIRA: Ist das ein neuer Schneebesen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Den probiere ich gerade aus.
Cool, nicht?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ela, du darfst Öl reinschütten.
Samira, den Joghurt.
>> ELA: Wow, wie schön das reinläuft!
>> SAMIRA: Eins, zwei, drei, Joghurtschlacht!
>> SALLY: Schön alles auskratzen.
Na, auch das Öl.
>> SAMIRA: Kann ich den Joghurt auskratzen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Können wir gleich das gleich...
>> SALLY: Wenn das Backen zur Nebensache wird.
>> ELA: Samira, du machst mit dem Löffel rein
>> ELA: und ich mache dann die ganze Schüssel rein.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay. Passt schon.
Jetzt kurz rühren.
>> ELA: Ich möchte rühren!
Backe, backe Kuchen, der Bäcker hat...
>> SALLY: Ihr lernt das echt toll!
Bald muss die Mama keinen Kuchen mehr backen
oder darf keinen Kuchen mehr backen.
Das macht ja dann ihr nur noch.
Hä?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh, oh!
Da bin ich jetzt aber schon traurig.
>> SAMIRA: Kommt das auch noch rein?
>> SALLY: Wartet. Da nehmen wir aber ein Sieb.
Guck mal, Samira. Das kannst du jetzt hier reinfüllen.
>> ELA: Und ich darf dann diesen machen
und Samira darf dann das machen.
Oder?
>> ELA: Samira rührt.
>> SALLY: Und dann darf Samira
>> SALLY: das Mehl mit dem Backpulver hier dazu sieben.
Guck mal. Das kannst du einfach so schütteln.
>> ELA: Samira,
>> SALLY: Zack, zack, zack.
>> ELA: möchtest du nicht rühren?
>> SALLY: Und unten ist ein Deckel.
>> ELA: Warte, Samira.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Und jetzt reinsieben.
Und, Ela, rühren, gell?
So.
>> SAMIRA: Müssen wir das nicht unterheben?
>> SALLY: Ja, das wird jetzt nur ganz vorsichtig
mit dem Schneebesen untergerührt.
Ganz vorsichtig!
Ich finde, in den Teig gehört auch noch Vanilleextrakt. Oder?
>> SAMIRA: Kann es die Ela machen?
>> SALLY: Ela, noch ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt in den Teig.
>> SAMIRA: Aber nur ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Ja, das reicht.
Reicht. Reicht. Reicht!
Ihr zwei habt getuschelt.
>> SAMIRA: Guck.
Letztes Mal hat sie zu wenig rein gemacht
und dieses Mal zu viel.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Soll ich dir mal helfen?
Wenn man es schneller macht, dann geht mehr durch,
weil es sich dann schneller dreht.
>> SAMIRA: Darf ich rühren, Ela?
>> ELA: Nein!
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe den noch gar nicht gerührt.
>> SALLY: Abla hat noch gar nicht gerührt.
Lass Abla auch rühren.
[Musik]
Komm mal. Lass Mama ganz kurz einmal durchrühren.
>> ELA: Mama, jetzt möchte ich.
>> SALLY: Jetzt haben wir alle gerührt, gell?
>> ELA: Jetzt ist jeder glücklich.
>> SALLY: Da, magst du
abschlecken?
Ja, jetzt ist jeder glücklich.
Sie haut die Sprüche raus,
die man eigentlich so als Mutter sagt. Oder?
>> ELA: Schleck mal.
>> SAMIRA: Mhm. Ich habe schon was.
Okay.
Während ihr zwei hier noch abschleckt,
kann ich schon mal den Teig einfüllen.
Sodele.
Jetzt fülle ich den Teig hier einfach ein.
Also ihr seht, es ist ein superschneller Kuchen.
Sogar mit Kindern schnell gebacken.
>> ELA: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Kriege ich den Teigschaber?
>> SALLY: Hier.
Okay.
Hier kommen jetzt noch
die Rhabarber- und Erdbeerstücke drauf.
Und dann kann der Kuchen gebacken werden.
Und wir können die Küche aufräumen!
Yay!
Ela, wir räumen die Küche auf, ja?
>> SALLY: Ela?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung?
Wir haben auch zusammen gebacken!
Wenn ich mit euch zusammen spiele,
dann räume ich auch mit euch die Spielsachen weg.
>> ELA: Erst mal bin ich ein Noob.
Dann bin ich
ein Pro-Noob. Dann bin ich ein richtiger Pro.
Und dann bin ich...
>> SALLY: Bist du ein Pro?
>> ELA: Nein, ich bin ein Noob.
>> SALLY: Ein Loob? Was ist das?
>> JOSH: Ein Noob.
>> SALLY: Noob? Was ist ein Noob?
>> JOSH: Weißt du das nicht?
>> SALLY: Was ist ein Noob?
>> ELA: Noob!
>> SALLY: Was ist das?
>> SAMIRA: Ein Anfänger!
In Minecraft!
>> SALLY: Warum kennt sie das, Josh?
Hat die einen Minecraft-Kanal?
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Kann man dich abonnieren?
>> SALLY: Echt?
Wie viele Subs hast du denn schon?
>> ELA: 100!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Ich bleibe beim Backen.
Der Kuchen kommt jetzt in den Backofen!
>> ELA: Ah, nein!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hauptsache, Ela trinkt.
Ela?
Soll ich dir das ausschaben?
So die Stärke mit
dem Rhabarber und mit der Erdbeere?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Schmeckt das dir?
Sehr gut!
>> ELA: Sehr gut.
>> SALLY: Ist halt ein schwäbisches Kind.
Da wird nichts verschwendet.
Man könnte meinen, du kriegst nur
vor der Kamera was zu essen.
So hinter der Kamera: Sally kocht nie zu Hause!
Sally backt nie Kuchen!
>> ELA: Kein Wunder, dass Papa nicht so viel backt wie du.
>> SALLY: Ela, backt die Mama auch ohne Kamera für euch?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Kocht sie auch für euch?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, gell?
Geht es dir gut hier im Haushalt?
Okay.
>> ELA: Daha iyi.
>> SALLY: Super.
Sehr gut!
Du kriegst später dein Geld dafür.
Ach, ihr zwei Mäuse!
Okay. Ich kann auch ohne euch aufräumen heute.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich rufe euch, wenn der Kuchen fertig ist, okay?
Okay, Ela?
>> ELA: Ich möchte wissen, wie Vanille schmeckt.
>> SALLY: Hast du gehört?
Ich rufe dich, wenn der Kuchen fertig ist.
>> ELA: Einen kleinen Löffel.
>> SALLY: Alle fragen sich jetzt:
Was heckt sie jetzt schon wieder aus?
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Ich sage doch, das ist Murats Kind.
Da...
>> ELA: Ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen. Aber jetzt dann ist gut.
>> ELA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Okay, Vanilleextrakt-Liebhaber.
Sallys Kind.
>> ELA: Und jetzt warten.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: 16:00 Uhr in Waghäusel.
Die Kinder sind gerade im Garten.
Der Kuchen ist abgekühlt.
Sally Özcan hat den Kuchen
mit einem Backformmesser aus der Form gelöst.
Danach hat sie durch eine elegante Handbewegung
das Backpapier unter dem Kuchen weggezogen,
um den Kuchen auf den Tortenteller zu transportieren.
Der Kuchen ist komplett abgekühlt,
wurde mit süßem Schnee bestreut und angeschnitten.
Jetzt kommt gleich Sarah.
Sarah P.
wird gleich den Kuchen probieren.
[Musik]
One,
two,
one, two, three, four.
>> SARAH: Ich habe es gewusst!
>> SALLY: Hast du gesehen?
Ich war voll im Rhythmus!
>> SARAH: Du warst richtig im Rhythmus.
>> SALLY: Okay, warte.
Nee, das waren Atemübungen bei der Geburt.
Okay.
One,
two,
one, two, three, four.
To the left, to the left.
>> SARAH: Mmm.
>> SALLY & SARAH: To the left, to the left.
>> SALLY: Strawberry rhubarb cake is on the left.
>> SARAH: In my belly
>> SALLY & SARAH: it's so yummy!
>> SALLY: Ups.
>> SARAH: Aber ich habe ihn noch gar nicht probiert.
>> SALLY: Wir haben weiter nicht mehr überlegt,
wie der Refrain aufhört.
>> SARAH: Das war gerade spontan.
Wir haben gar nichts überlegt.
>> SALLY: Ja. It's so yummy!
Probier den Kuchen jetzt!
>> SARAH: Okay.
Mit dem Mikro.
>> SALLY: Das Mikrofon unterstützt unsere Seriosität.
>> SARAH: Dann fühlt man es mehr.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Ich fühle es auch.
>> SARAH: Deshalb fühlst du...
>> SALLY: Ich fühle es.
>> SARAH: Du fühlst es auch so richtig.
Ich probiere den.
>> SALLY: Ich fühle es.
Wenn wir auf Tour gehen,
du so und ich so.
>> SARAH: Dann kannst du besser tanzen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Ich kann...
>> SALLY: Dann habe ich beide Hände frei.
Okay.
>> SARAH: Ich zittere.
Wenn ich so lachen muss, muss ich so zittern.
Und dann kann ich nicht essen.
>> SALLY: Ist ein Strawberry-Rhabarber-Cake.
>> SARAH: Das habe ich aus unserem Lied entnommen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mit...
>> SARAH: Süß und säuerlich.
>> SALLY: Zitronenabrieb.
>> SARAH: Und Joghurt.
>> SALLY: Und Joghurt.
>> SARAH: Sehr lecker!
Sehr lecker!
Ich bin das Mikro nicht gewohnt so.
>> SALLY: Könnt ihr eine Bauchbinde machen?
Sally und Sarah,
>> SARAH: Wir sind bald auf Tour!
>> SALLY: 14 und 15 Jahre alt.
>> SARAH: Ich bin auch schon 15.
>> SALLY: Ach, wie so ein Mädchenkanal.
Ja.
>> SARAH: SingStar-Kanal.
>> SALLY: Möchtet ihr,
dass wir einen SingStar-Kanal machen?
Dann kommentiert!
>> SARAH: Wir gehen...
Wir gehen auf Tour!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und?
Wie schmeckt er?
>> SARAH: Voll lecker!
>> SARAH: Dieses Säuerliche und Süße
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: passt sehr gut.
>> SALLY: Passt?
>> SALLY: Mit süßem Schnee drauf.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: So ein schöner Sonntagskuchen,
den man mal einfach schnell machen kann.
Ja.
Den hatte ich neulich übrigens
>> SALLY: auch in einem Live-Video gemacht.
>> SARAH: Geht der schnell?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Aha.
>> SALLY: Also mit Kindern...
>> SARAH: Stimmt.
>> SALLY: Mit Kindern zehn Minuten Zubereitungszeit,
ohne Kinder
fünf.
>> SARAH: Zum Glück habe ich keine Kinder.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SARAH: Dann geht es bei mir nur eine Stunde.
>> SALLY: Du hast nur eine Katze, gell?
>> SARAH: Ich habe eine Katze,
die schönste.
>> SALLY: Können wir kurz ein Bild von Katalea einblenden?
>> SARAH: Wir blenden...
Ich habe ein paar.
>> SALLY: Okay. Wir blenden jetzt im Anschluss
>> SARAH: Ich habe viele.
>> SALLY: die Bilder von Sarahs Handy ein.
Alle Bilder von...
>> SARAH: Eine Diashow.
>> SALLY: Wir machen jetzt eine Diashow.
>> SARAH: Ihr könnt noch 20 Minuten weiterschauen.
>> SALLY: Wir ziehen das Video um eine weitere...
Halbe Stunde?
>> SARAH: Ohne Werbepause.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Die folgenden Sendungen können sich
um eine Stunde verschieben.
Also backt den Kuchen gerne nach!
Probiert ihn aus.
Postet ihn! Markiert mich auf euren Fotos!
Da kommentiere ich auch regelmäßig
und schaue mir eure Bilder an.
Und jetzt viel Spaß mit der Diashow!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> SARAH: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Diashow.
Die glauben jetzt, wir machen es nicht.
Aber wir machen es.
>> SARAH: Wir machen es,
die Diashow.
>> SALLY: To the right, to the right.
>> SARAH: Und die Tour!
>> SALLY: Mmm.
[Musik]